[音楽]
me
[拍手]
[音楽]
どうも皆様こんにちは伊藤です
それではですね今日はこのナノセルロースまセルロースナノファイバー
まぁこ先端素材なんですけどこういうもののご説明から
や実は先端素材ってわりと身近だったなと感じていただければと
ようなお話をさせていただきます
あとあの話はすごく変わるんですけど例えばこれある主婦の会はねぇ
うちの主人は会社で
ナノセルロースの合成をしてますけどなんだかかっこいいですよね
もう一人の種がうちの主人はあの会社で材木を細くしています
ランダムな格好悪いですよねでもこの2つって同じ意味なんですよ
だけどその言葉っていうのはすごく不思議でナノセルロースティックと先端になって
財務を毎日細かくしているっていうとなんとなく先端に聞こえない
こういう言葉のマジックがあるんで実は先端材料ってのは皆様がなかなかあの身近に
感じないというものになると思います
ナノセルロースたらこちらに書いてありますよですね
7っていうサイズを表す言葉とセルロースという素材を表す言葉があのうくっついた
ものになります
まず最初にこのサイズを表す7という言葉説明しています
今回で様々あの長さで少しで起こってみましょう
ここに1m という長さがあります
これをどんどん大きくするときローダとかですね
アメリアの牛丼とか携帯を聞いたことあるんですか目がと鍵がとかそういう言葉になり
ますじゃあ今度どんどん短くしていくとどうなるか
短くしていくと3位だとかマイクロだとかでここではじめてなのっていう言葉が出てき
ます
7っていうのは実は
1メートルの木材を10億等分した
1個のサイズがありますでちょっとまだわかりにくいと思いますので
例えば
子宮がもし1m だとしたら1なのってだいたいどのくらいの大きさになると思います
ちょっと皆さんなイメージしてください
実は
パチンコ玉一つくらいの大きさなんですですから7ってのはそのくらいものすごくちい
ちゃん世界だというふうに思ってください
次に今度セルロース
セルロースという言葉ですけど聞いたことがあると思います
あの子の写真見たことある道ですけどこの木材の輪切りになっているところですけど
ここをもう少しどんどん拡大していくと
実はこちらにあるように蜂の巣みたいな構造になってて
まあそれをさらに死徒のそう削っていくとそこならにこういう繊維のようなものが入っ
ています
実はこれを構成している主成分の1つがセルロースと
いうものになります
でまぁあまり気なり難しい話をしても思いますけど皆さんこの化学式見てこれが何が
わかる人おられます
多分ものすごく我々生きるためにはすごく必要な物質になります
これはブドウ糖と呼ばれるものであります
セルロースっていうのはこのブドウ糖がオモテとウラオモテとウラ
こういう形で打っついたモノセロス分子と言います
ちなみに表通してくっついたものはでんぷんになります
ですからこのブドウ糖をベースとしたこのセルロース分子が何本もつながったものが
セルロースという風に呼ばれます
なんとなくイメージしていただくとこのさけるチーズとかカニカマですね
セルをさこういう形で構成されていると思ってください
で
多分まあ葬儀でも興味ここにおられる皆さんのほとんどが毎日セルロースに触ってい
ます
もっと言うと今も触っている方が何人か我々から見たらいいます
セルロースっていうのは今木材の構成成分だということで当然木材
っていうのはセルロースという素材が入っていますそれ以来に神だとか
衣類こういうもの方実はもう面ですねこれもセルロースはできていますあとここには
書いてないですけれども
プラッシュ救世いセルロイドとかですねレイヨンとかこういうものも線ロース
から作っていますしあとは食品なんかにも入っていますそれからさらには火薬花火の
火薬もセルロースが原料で作られているものが色々あります
ということでこのセルロースとすごく身近な存在になります
じゃああの世このナノセルロースと組み合わさった時のあの言葉の説明をしていきたい
とおもいます
この写真を見てですねこれなんて何かわかるかなと聞いてもまああの写真があまり多く
ないんではあのわかんないかもしれんですけどまぁ寒天みたいなもんですよね
これ実はナタデココです
でなたレポコンっていうのはココナッツの魅力を
なた金という酢酸菌の一種なんですけどもそのなた金が合成をして分解をしてあの
できるもので実はこの中でボコっていうのは
99%の水と1%だけのセルロースナノファイバーでできています
これすご少し guys 品の1%だけ水に入る入るだけで本来形のなかったものが
すごくしっかりした形になってしまうなあなあのファイバーてなんかすげー
在廊なんじゃないかというふうにいろんな世界中の研究者が思いまして
でナノファイバーの研究ってのは今世界的にいろんなところでやれ
思います
でナノファイバーじゃあ作りましょうと今酢酸菌で作りましょうと言ったんですけど
まぁ金で作ってでも時間がかかりますので
ナノファイバーンっていうのは実は意外に簡単に作れます
ここの説明はしないですけどもまぁ先ほどさけるチーズカニカマと言いましたけど水の
中にさけるチーズを入れてどんどん縫うだけですで最終的な
のサイズもにちっちゃくしたのがこんな形のナノセルロースになります
でこのナノセルロースっていうのはまぁ実際には非常に強度が強かったり
名乗ってサイズ光の波長いる小さいですから透明になったりあるいは安全植物由来です
から安全な天然素材というふうに言われています
じゃあ今までなんで俺製品として出て来なかったので実はとっても難しい the いる
んです
ちょっと話は変わりますけど世の中の物質っていうのはすべて
表面を安定させようとしています
例えば鉄でも主要でも
一つの物体でも中と外では原子構造が原子構造あるいは分子構造
これが全く違ってます常にあの惣菜というのは安定化安定化だろうというふうになって
います
これはどんなものもそうですあの今日もうちょっと話がありますから朝ですね私は女房
に浜松駅まで送ってもらったんです
とまぁ以来不機嫌でですね朝9時にここに来なかったらいけなかったんだよ
日曜日の日には贈られるまあ不機嫌だったんですけどそういうふうにどうするか私も
物質ですから
表明を作ろうってですね円満な家庭をまあ築こうとしている
さあそういう意味ではどんな存在でも表面を安定だしようとするものがあります
でこれはな載せるのそうなった今回です
ナノセルロース3を買って観ていただくと実は安定化しようという表面が微すごく
たくさんあります
そういうことでナノセルロース同士がもったい手を繋いでしまう
そろそろどんどん手をつなぐとせっかくなのになったのにまた元のミクロ
あるいはミニ下手したらメートルまで戻ってしまうのでこれを使うがすごく難しい
で減給開発っていうのは実はこの難しいことにチャレンジするからモチベーションある
ず誰でもできることをやったらモチベーションじゃないんです
だこれは我々研究者はみんな本来無理なようなことを通してやっていきたいかっていう
のが一つのこのセルロースナノファイバーは我々研究者側からも夢の素材とあの使い手
側からも夢の素材
と言われますけど夢の素材というふうに言われています
でじゃあ今同様に使われているかと言うと
まぁまずはですね注目されているようとってない自動車のもやですよ非常にある
セルロース明るいですから軽い素材で補強しますのでまぁ自動車が軽量化になるま燃費
が向上するあるいは今商品になっているものとすると
まああの三菱のボールペンですねこういうボールペンある
インクがかすれないように7回かが入っていないあと
紙おむつやなんかに入れてニオイの兄甥の吸着らとか
だから消臭効果を出すというような形でまあ使われています
でまぁ今ナノファイバーでなぜここまで聞くとやっぱり先端な材料だよねと思うんです
けど実は簡単にできます
野菜から
野菜を
巡査で混ぜただけでセルロースナノファイバーできます
あの皆さん食物繊維という言葉聞いたことあります食物繊維てんだいたオーバーさせる
ぞ
音をさしまして実は簡単にセローさあの梅婆っていうのはみなさん作ることができます
でじゃあこのセルロースナノファイバーを作る時に
じゃあマヨネーズとかソースこんな調味料を入れたらどうなるんでしょう
せ風呂さんの方が先いっぱいてがありますいろんなものを打ってつなぎたいと思ったん
です
そうするともしかするとたまたま
ケチャップてをツナマヨネーズの手をつなぐことがあるかもしれません
こういうようなあの新しいリアの調味料っていうのはもしかしたらできるかもしれない
です
どんな味するかわかんないですけどもまぁそういう量にっていうのは実は非常に料理に
も
せるをさあの方々使えるということになります
でここで私が言いたいのは実はこの新しいレシピがもしかしたらできるということは実
はこれは新しい花が分半
ということだ皆さんが台所で作ったものがもしかしたらノーベル賞になるかもしれない
んだから実はすごく身近なものだというイメージを持って頂ければというふうに思い
ます
でまぁ最後になりますけれどもあの
まあこのサイエンスって言葉を聞くとなんかものすごくこれは科学者が言っているよう
な言葉でちょっと私は私たちは関係ないだけですねという風に思われるかもしれないん
ですけど
サイエンスてのひも解くとある出来事を通して何だろうと考えてそして持った1
は挑戦するこれがサイエンス
だからたとえば恋愛でもそう料理でもそうスポーツでもそう
どれも全部実はこのサイエンスっていうのをしてますですからサイエンスっていうのに
サボン
科学者だけのものじゃないと思っています
であの我々例えば料理でセルロースナノファイバーで新しいものができた
そしたら我々はそれをどうなんねんり元素がどうなんだっていうを求めながらあの
新しいものを作っていくってのは非常に楽しいことでもしかするとまぁ皆さんこんな
稼働子さんがですね
おられてそれ料理をする中でサイエンスということを
を得てですね何十年後ノーベル賞を取ったときにそのお子様がですね
本場の金具者になられた時や子どもの頃にナノファイバーの料理を作って僕は科学が
好きになりましたという風に言ってもらったらなんとなく今我々こういう研究やってる
人間からもんさきほどボート work ワークという言葉がありましたけど
わくわくすると思いますんで皆さんもあの騙されたと思って食物繊維で体にいいです
からいろいろちょっとあの
野菜ジュースで遊んでいただいたらどうでしょうかどうも今日はこれで終わります
ありがとうございます
[拍手]